(gentle music)
- [Narrator] One of the world's
biggest traffic jams isn't
on a road or highway.
It's at the Panama Canal.
By the end of August,
a backlog of more than 200 ships waited
for weeks to pass through the waterway.
Some were stalled for more than 20 days.
- We handle about $600
billion worth of merchandise
through the Panama Canal.
- [Narrator] And this vital
trade route is at risk.
The cause a historic drought.
The delays are rippling
through the global economy
as lower water levels cut
into shipping times and bottom lines.
Here's how the Panama Canal
is adapting to a drier planet
and what those changes mean
for the global supply chains
and industries that depend on it.
(bright music)
(explosion booming)
When the Panama Canal
first opened in 1914,
it was a game changer for
the shipping industry.
- [Narrator] A little job
connecting the Atlantic
and Pacific.
- [Narrator] For the first time,
cargo ships could save
about five days traveling
between the Atlantic and Pacific.
Bypassing this treacherous journey
around the tip of South America.
By connecting two oceans,
countries with vast distances between them
could now compete in Global Trade.
But as the canal runs out of water,
canal operators like Ricaurte Vasquez
are scrambling to protect the root.
Vasquez is the head administrator
for the Panama Canal Authority,
which maintains and operates the waterway.
- We handle about 55%
of all containers that go to
the United States from Asia.
We do that in about
13,000 transits per year,
in regular times.
- [Narrator] Ships like
this one are elevated
to about 85 feet above sea level
through a system of locks
and then lowered down on the other end.
Every time a ship passes through
as much as 120 million gallons
of water are lost to the sea
that's enough to fill as many
as 244 Olympic sized swimming pools.
All of that water comes from a system
of freshwater reservoirs and
rivers that depend on rainfall.
- It operates on fresh water,
which is a major difference,
compared to any other major
waterway in the world.
We cannot pump water from
the oceans into the lake.
- [Narrator] Even though Panama
is the world's fifth rainiest country,
it no longer has a steady
supply of fresh water.
- Over the last 20 years,
there is a downward trend
in water precipitation.
We were 89 feet over sea level.
Nowadays, we are 79 feet over sea level,
so that is a 10 feet reduction
on the lake level in a
relatively sizable lake.
- [Narrator] Lower water
levels are a problem
for cargo ships that sometimes carry
as many as 16,000 containers at a time.
If ships are too heavy,
they risk getting trapped in the canal.
- We have to introduce draft restrictions,
which imposes that every
vessel has to come lighter
or with less cargo in order to sail
through the Panama Canal.
- [Narrator] A ship's draft
limit is the minimum depth
of water a vessel can safely navigate.
This decides how much
cargo a vessel can carry
without getting stuck.
As drought conditions
worsened over the summer,
the waterway reduced its draft
limit from 50 feet to 44.
- For a container vessel, on the average,
every feet of draft represents
about 300 to 350 containers.
- [Narrator] Since may,
large container vessels like this one
have had to reduce cargo
loads by as much as 25%.
- That of course, means that
we can offer less capacity
to our customers as a result of this.
- [Narrator] Lars Oestergaard Nielsen
is the Head of Customer Delivery
in the Americas at Maersk.
The world's second largest
cargo shipping carrier
in terms of capacity.
- We actually sail extra
ships to fill in the blanks,
because we lose this six feet of water,
we lose an opportunity to load some cargo.
(engine revving)
- [Narrator] Other ship
owners are adjusting
to the restrictions by offloading
their cargo onto trains.
The boxes are unloaded from ships
on one side of the canal,
moved by rail and returned
to the vessels before they
continue their voyage.
But the system doesn't
work for all cargo ships.
- If you are a bulk carrier,
you taking coal, grain,
there is no way to unload.
So you have to come light and
you come light from origin,
then you look for another port destination
to increase your cargo
and then take it to the final destination.
- [Narrator] In an effort
to save even more water,
the canal has limited the amount
of vessels that are allowed
to pass through each day,
but fewer ships traveling
through the canal, means longer
wait times and higher tolls.
Shipping executives say container vessels,
now pay around $400,000
to cross the waterway.
That includes a fresh water surcharge
of more than 10%, meaning
the lower the water levels,
the more shipping companies have to pay.
- So far, what we have tried is to reduce
from 36 transits per day
to 32 transits per day.
So there are a lot less
spaces to have an option
for standby customers.
Of the 30 slots or 32 slots that we offer
about 28 of them are already booked.
- [Narrator] Container
ships that are able to book
in advance, typically aren't impacted
by these types of bottlenecks,
but vessels that aren't on fixed routes,
like bulk and gas carriers
that move cargo on short notice
face the longest wait times.
The delays for these types
of non-book vessels
increased 280% since June.
That's according to project44.
A supply chain visibility platform.
On top of the delays,
bulk carriers are also
facing higher auction fees.
- There are now an opportunity
to go into an auction
where you can basically
bid for getting access
to these limited time slots
that were not booked early.
Now those auctions have
gone the highest I have seen
and the highest number we have
seen is a level of $900,000.
- [Narrator] To make up
for the higher costs,
ship owners are charging customers
about $600 more per cargo container.
- There's no doubt that
the canal is very important
for global trade.
If the canal was not there
then that would essentially add more cost.
It would add delays.
- [Narrator] Disruptions
in the canal's operations
could hurt southern hemisphere exporters
and northern importers.
Brazilian meat, Chilean wines
and bananas from Ecuador
are regularly shipped across the canal.
Copper from Chile and natural gas
from the US Gulf Coast
transit the waterway too.
It's also one of the fastest
and least expensive ways to move grain
and other agricultural commodities,
which leave the port of
New Orleans for China.
About 73% of all the traffic
passing through the canal
is either headed for or
leaving the United States.
But shipping executives say
increasing transit times
and costs are leading some bulk carriers
to seek out alternate routes.
Vessels carrying products
to customers in Asia,
may sail through the Suez Canal
or around the Cape of Good Hope,
adding one to two weeks to the journey.
- It's basically your
products that's in break bulk
or in tanker.
So this could be oil,
it could be natural gas,
it could be grain products.
- [Narrator] For now, Maersk
and other large container
ship companies have no plans
to divert their core
shipments away from Panama.
Still, executives say,
it's not off the table
if drought conditions worsen.
- Yes, we have a problem.
We acknowledge this will
impair your operation,
but in order to minimize
the adverse effect of it,
we are providing the information,
so you make the best decision based
on real data on real-time.
- [Narrator] The canal's future now hinges
on $2 billion plan to divert as many
as four additional
rivers into the waterway.
That's an addition to the three
rivers that already feed it.
But adding new reservoirs is a costly
and lengthy undertaking.
New water would have to come
from watersheds that are
farther from the canal,
requiring the construction
of tunnels as well as dams.
River diversions also put pressure
on the region's limited water sources,
which support over 2 million people
and the surrounding rainforest ecosystems.
Ultimately, canal operators
are working to maintain a balance
between the water needs of
the canal, the environment
and Panama's growing urban population.
- We have to make provisions
to supply fresh water
for water consumption well
in advance economic growth
and population growth.
There is a slight competition
between water for transit and
water for human consumption.
- [Narrator] The Panama Canal
Authority is also investing
in new infrastructure
outside of the waterway.
- We are thinking about roads,
we are thinking about storage facilities,
we're thinking about complimentary
services to be provided
for cargoes that can wait in Panama
to find the final destination.
- [Narrator] These changes
were meant to be carried out
over 25 years, but administrators say,
drought and changing
weather patterns has cut
that timeline down to 10.
Canal operators see this
crisis as an opportunity
to fast track critical
infrastructure buildouts.
- The opportunity is now
because there is a high level
of awareness of the situation.
People have a sense
of what the value of not
having fresh water means.
(gentle music)